what's on your phone oh man what's the
app that people might be most surprised
to learn is on your phone
I have Pokemon go I mean I feel like
everyone's gonna say that now just
because I didn't know what it was
I love Pokemon but I wasn't that I could
understand what everyone was going so
crazy I got a perfect 365 it is
Instagram post it's just it kind of just
like it just puts makeup on but like you
can go really natural so I have like
four note applicant applications like no
pet what a nerd right affirmation apps
okay they're just like you're great like
they do it push you notifications like
daily affirmation you can set it up to
do that I used them like once like I
just had one bad day I was like I need
some help here what's the app you can't
live without on your phone are YouTube
creators are you too clear to see you I
think like uber these days I I use my
phone as a camera more than in as Faiza
phone I love I love snapping and I'm
always like on Twitter on snapchat
Instagram that the whole thing yeah once
I think Twitter Instagram yeah somewhere
in there but I guess the one that's most
uses like Google like honestly like I'm
always just on Google like what is it
bulbasaur evolution I forgot I forgot
the second one it was Ivysaur those oh
that's not blue heeler
what's your favorite emoji just a
regular face but then like that oh I
like the awkward that face okay I like
the confetti like use that to everything
thank you see you at three favorite
might be the upside no upside down smile
okay
I still die that you tried to go up guys
if you could aside like I like it cuz
it's not actually possible I love monkey
emoji oh can you can you guys hold my
ears if you were going to try this oh
you wanna thank you hey guys if you
liked what you saw make sure to
subscribe